ce nouveau lieu d'échangé et de travail
est composé de trois petites salles
isolé réservables en ligne d'une grande
salle de réunion modulables et d'un
petit amphithéâtre ouvert tient lieu de
vie auquel ils peuvent s'approprier en
dehors en dehors des horaires de cours
est donc c'est un lieu ici où il pour
venir travailler seul ou à plusieurs
mais également un lieu de convivialité
d'interaction et des espaces de détente
un projet nécessaire surtout après la
crise sanitaire qui a chamboulé le monde
étudiant va presque vrai qu'on a connu
c'était hyper important pour possession
de ces campus de sa composante ici
d'avoir un lieu de vie un lieu de
travail un lieu partagé en fait pour
faire du un peu de lien social et puis
c'est un lieu qui est désagréable très
agréable un nouvel espace de travail qui
vient compléter la bibliothèque
universitaire et la maison de l'étudiant
il allait à la bibliothèque de saint
quentin où il ya aussi des salles de
travail mais il y en a trop court
il a déjà la maison d'étudiant e
sinon ils se réunissent et ce dans des
salles de cours qui était qui est
évident qu'il ya de vrai lieu de vie
dédiée dédié à sap coût des travaux
577000 euros auquel l'état a participé à
hauteur de 200 mille euros et la
contribution de vie étudiante et de
campus à hauteur de 246 milles euros